You know how
people
even
off the
wigs.
And of
where women
I I
been to that
years
and now
fortune.
What's
to their
Mecca
the
[Silence]
dirty clothes that are full of sin and
make oaf around the Kaa. No, you've got
to buy a fresh set of clothes just for
that arrival. And it has to be from the
people of Mecca, from those who reside
in Mecca. Well, what about if you can't
afford it? Well, then you're going to
make Baf naked. And that's what they
did.
Because the businessmen of Mecca,
Abu Jah, Abuab,
they would rather these people come and
circumambulate the Kaa in the nude
than to not buy their products,
right? And so
it wasn't just an issue of religion for
a lot of them. Yes, it was that for
some. But just as today, not all people
are religious or particularly spiritual.
Things were that back then as well.
You have your businessman's
,
you know, agenda. You have the
shrinekeeper man, you know, their
agenda. You have the different
characters that are all benefiting from
the fables and the tales and the
superstitions
of
the
idols of Mecca and the surrounding
idols.
Anyone know is another idol.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam said at
the end of time before the hour starts
that people will resurrect
and
they will worship these idols again
is the main idol from the land of do.
Who is from do?
The land of do has their idol
and has their idol
right of
has their idol of
and the other places they have their
respective idols and shrines and people
come in droves to come and visit these
idols. So you you're coming now with
this
Allah.
We can't just allow this to happen.
There's only one create only one who's
worthy of worship. We cannot worship
anyone or anything else. No.
Therefore, all of these things are to be
taken off of the board. And now what
happens?
My father's father's father,
you know, was a devote of Allet
and my father and his father and his
father before him and we are all the
gatekeepers of Allet for generations.
Now you're telling me all of that was
invalid.
And so it's the implications ofahill.
So Allah tells the prophet Sam,
they wish
that you would compromise
so that they could compromise with you.
What did their compromise look like?
Well, for instance,
one of the things, one of the ideas that
they floated was, look, we will worship
Allah alone without any partners for an
entire year
and then
we will the following year you all will
worship with us our gods for a year. For
an entire year we will pray and do
everything as Muslim and only worship
Allah and then the following year you
guys now
worship with us. And can this happen on
the individual level
a per one person you or me in our
work in our job with our can this happen
with with people where this this verse
would apply.
What about if someone says look I'll
come to the masid with you to become
Muslim if you come to my temple with me.
This is not outlandish. I I would wager
that maybe more than half of us here
have had such a such a an offer made
to them, a co-orker, a neighbor, right?
Come to church mass with me on Sunday
and I'll go to I'll go to Friday prayer
with you. Come with me on Friday and
I'll come with you on Friday and you
come with me on Sunday. right?
celebrate Christmas with us and we'll
celebrate Eid with you. You're in you're
in your work. We can have aid party and
we can have a Christmas party.
Balance it out. Right.
Now, if you accept offers this,
what happens?
What happens when a person accepts such
offers? Now these offers were made to
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
in various ways but they can still be
made to us today individually and we
have to figure out each one of these
verses how they apply to us today.
Now when you accept such offers when you
do such things what happens what is the
result
for us we may have good intentions
our intention may be I'm trying to you
know
you know I'm trying to
you know bring them to Islam and invite
them to Islam and so on and so forth.
Well, what happens? What happens when
we give and take in this way? We give
and take in holiday celebration. We give
and take in worship. We give and take
and it cheapens what we have.
You lose your credibility.
Very good. Correct. That's exactly what
happens because what do you do? You take
the Quran and you place it right on the
shelf next to all the other books. It's
one of many books, right? That's the
kind of Islam
that our colonizers want.
Those who have colonized our minds, they
want that kind of Islam. The kind of
Islam where we have the red dots right
next to the hijab, right next to the th
right next to the Harry Krishna garb
right next to we want to have a a a
place where we have one big parking lot
and you've got a mosque, a church, a
synagogue, a temple all in the same
place a strip mall. Okay? And we
all visit with each other and we all do.
This is what we want.
So that you will take Islam and make it
just one more opinion
amongst the other opinions. One more of
the many paths that lead to Rome.
But listen to how strict our prophet was
in adhering to this verse.
The prophet Sami
was once asked
that a man had vowed to slaughter a
camel in an area called Buana.
Buana was just a place in the outskirts
of Mecca.
And
if you could imagine with me, Mecca is
kind of a county.
Okay? And within it there are different
areas, right? There's different
townships or villages just today.
They have different names. Bu is a place
on the outskirts of Mecca.
And this man had vowed to Allah to
slaughter a camel in that area called
Buana.
Now
a person's antenni should go up when
they hear such a vow. Why? Why Buana?
Why there specifically?
Why there?
Why do you vow to slaughter there
specifically?
Why not just anywhere in Mecca?
Why not just I vow to slaughter a camel
for Allah? Why does it have to be in
Buana or Melifa or Mina or Hudabia? Why
buana specifically?
And so
he told the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam that he had made this vow in
should he fulfill this vow.
And so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam asked him two questions.
He said
he said is that a place
where
idoltors go to slaughter for other than
Allah for their idols? Is that why you
chose Buana?
He said no.
He said
he said is that an area that the mushri
go to visit or celebrate there?
They said no. Meaning it has no
religious significance to the idoltors.
And so he said
in that case fulfill your vow.
Meaning that if thou were a place where
other than Allah was slaughtered for not
permissible it is not permissible to
slaughter for Allah in a place that
other than Allah is worshiped.
That's how far the prophet understood.
We're not even going to mix places.
We're not even going to worship Allah in
the same place you worship Allah in the
other than Allah in the same way that
you worship other than Allah. A person
may say, well, didn't they used to pray
to their idols in the Kaa?
And the prophet used to pray at the Kaa
even when the idols were there. We say
yes. But the salah of the muslim is
different than the salah of the mushri
to their idols. You would not confuse
the two. But slaughtering looks to be
the same, right? And that in the future,
generations forward will merge the two
religions. And we are not the same. We
will not even be confused for a moment
by an onlooker. This is how our prophet
understood these verses.
And so tomorrow night inshallah
Saturday night
maybe Sunday night now one of these
nights the next time we talk about this
we will take two examples of mud
from the prophet and we will take not
from him from other people obviously the
the mushikian or those who compromised
and we will take a couple of example
examples of mud
which is the difference between being
politic political and diplomatic and
being compromising and accommodating.
Those two things are not the same and we
will take inshallah examples from both
so that both are clear in our minds.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahuaala
samu.